hello look at the game sports coverage
of penny arcade expo 2014 live from
sector G gamespot's Giant Bomb kind of
fell yet cheer gon go for it you can't
see but there's a bunch of people behind
me right now drinking coffee and playing
video games and stuff I'm delighted to
be joined by crashed and filled Rob
turlock studios how's it going gentlemen
hey goon hey you just got in there last
night you enjoying the packs experience
yeah yeah I got to see about two hours
of it before it ended yesterday so today
bright and early how do you been in
today yeah yeah dead you do you guys
because you your booth is absolutely
massive in the North all you've got that
big monster but the real life any
nonsense and stuff I do get to spend
much time away from the booth have you
actually to peruse yeah they're nice
enough to give us you know a little
break you know so that we can go out and
look around yeah but really got much of
a chance to do that yet I don't think
either one of us has but first time it
packs for both of us oh yeah yeah
excellent what's not like having like
because your booth is quite large and
you're laying a lot of people to
actually get hands-on time with above
and it's kind of one of those games that
I feel you need to play to sort of get
the nuance and what's it like actually
seeing people playing it and like
getting their feedback or even just
their passive feedback by watching them
it's pretty awesome and then you know we
had to keep this game secret for years
yeah you know we're not allowed to talk
about it and certainly once we were
allowed to talk about and actually get
it in people's hands that's you know
that's what we want right we have that
we have the same thing with left for
dead yeah left 4 dead was a similar game
where you really had to play it and
experience it in order to really get
like how fun hmm it wasn't addictive you
know they get in there in place so
you know we release from the beginning
the first thing we did was when we
announced the game we had people play it
and and so pax is like the perfect place
yeah to get as many people in there as
we can I'm left for dead is a game that
kind of evolved with its community as
well like you it seems like you guys
were like listening to people and
changing stuff like has there been any
fundamental changes to evolve has there
been like ideas that you've sort of
implemented that you might not
necessarily done if you hadn't got
feedback people i think maybe more like
adjustments made ok so i mean early on
when i first started showing evolve one
of the things that people really latched
onto was all the wildlife and the
environment they wanted kind of some
more reasons to interact with that
wildlife and that's where the elites
come from there you have these elite
wildlife that you can get buffs from
both teams can get bus from them and we
had those in there but we didn't have
very many and so we really kind of went
all out on those and made one for each
species and really populate the map zone
so just adjustments to the game doing
more of the things that people are
excited about and and then you know any
sort of frustrations we see Phil and I
were talking today about you know when
when Goliath folds is rock up to go
throw it sometimes it blocks the camera
so we're going to go back and we're
gonna fix that you know I think as
developers we often we work around those
issues yeah you know we kind of even
subconsciously were used to it and so
see people play it for the first time he
reminds you like a fresh perspective to
fix that yeah add it to the list and so
on gamespot we tend to have a lot of
people who know a lot of it evolve and
then we have people who don't really
know anything about it so for the folks
of really don't know what's the sort of
elevator page on evolve or so evolved is
a four verses 1 cooperative competitive
shooter I've said that 300,000 essentia
but you know sort of the way it plays
out is it's it's kind of like a big epic
drawn-out boss battle I mean you've got
four cooperative players we're huge fans
of co-op you know that's what
like on the hunters side and then you
know one guy gets to be the monster who
was you know he's all by his lonesome
but he's a powerhouse and you can really
sort of bring the fight that's a guy
being the boss being the boss monster in
this game that was kind of one of the
things that we really like the idea of
like your everybody who's ever played
games have fought against a boss right
and now you get to be the boss and it
was like Anna left 4 dead when you were
doing the sort of humans vs zombies mode
everyone sort of propagated towards one
particular type of zombie maybe that was
always like that one that ever wanted to
do and let's look at the gameplay we're
looking at here so this is the Goliath
correct yeah I yeah and he's staged up
right now so what he's doing is putting
points into abilities he's choosing
which abilities he wants to take and
they making them more powerful so over
time the monsters the monster has to
kill wildlife and eat it and get energy
and then that lets him stage up and give
you bigger and stronger so obviously the
that's bad for the humans they don't
want him to get bigger and stronger they
want to they want to try to stop him so
he's Stage three right now that's as big
as they can get and so the hunters
they're going to have a really tough
fight on their hands the nice thing for
the hunters though is that he just came
out of his his cocoon so he doesn't have
he hasn't had a chance to build up any
armor so all the damage they're doing to
him right now is permanent and so now
we're in first person one of the hunters
you guys have kind of gone pretty deep
on the classes for a specific character
stuff you talked a little bit though
because it seems like you very much half
your particular role within the comp lab
yeah that and that kind of comes from
with having left for dead under our belt
we sort of figured out co-op and and how
to make co-op fun yeah and we end and
because we had the lone wolf side of the
game to be in the monster where you
didn't have co-op we felt like we could
in this game we had the ability to go
deeper into co-op and so breaking that
down into classes and giving people
specific roles is just is one of the
ways to do that it actually enables the
team to work better together because if
you're the medic then I know what you're
supposed to do and you know what I
supposed to do right so that ever
worried because in left 4 dead like
those roles kind of happened organically
like when you were playing maybe you
know your buddy who wasn't very good at
shooting became the sort of support guy
or like a medic or something was there
ever worry within the studio that like
if you're asking people to do specific
tasks in one way you're kind of limiting
them no I don't think we had any worries
i mean the the the classes were sort of
born out of play testing right i mean
one of the things sort of our poor you
know principles of turtle rock is to get
it up and running as quickly as possible
and play it you know i mean even if it's
ugly right it lets you find the fun
super quick you know sort so over time
you know as we've been playing it it
just sort of i think naturally happened
it just felt right so we added it and
yeah yeah and then and then one of the
things that we do one of the things
we're letting people do here at pax for
the first time because we've got
multiple hunters in every class so if
you like being a medic
we have different medics to choose from
they all play different and they also
have different personalities and
backstories and attitudes you know and
different conversations happen in the
game so we really kind of the characters
were very successful and left for dead I
mean even though they played the same
you know some people love being Zoe and
the actual looking for instance him and
even if and even if and all of those
characters had personalities you got to
know Prince it's over time and it's the
same in our game so you know bucket he's
a robot and he's he's got one of the
coolest personalities in the whole game
yep and so one of the other so the
linchpins of left 4 dead was the fact
that all the maps were tied together
gather narrative Lee and is there any of
that stuff having involved is there a
back story there's a motivation of the
Kraken there there is and and and it'll
come out in the game when you guys start
to play those and we have some more kind
of ways to play the game that we haven't
really talked about this sort of tie all
the maps together I mean the stories we
call emergent storytelling right it's
kind of the story you get to learn as
you play through the game and you play
different characters they'll say things
you'll see things in the environment
that sort of start to give you clue so
it's not we don't spoon feed you the
story story so to speak but it's kind of
one of those things that you know this
is a game that we want people to play
for a long time so as you play over you
know months and you know and go through
the different characters you learn
different things about them and the
story and sort of start to piece it
together and one of the best
achievements in left 4 dead was how map
variety created such different types of
gameplay and different types of battles
obviously we're looking at this sort of
this arctic swampy tundra type thing
what move what are you guys doing in
terms of map variety not just in terms
of how they look but in terms of how
they play like scale size finest like
well one of the things that we did real
early was we didn't we specifically
didn't give them the mappers to level
designers any sort of parameters like we
didn't give them any limitations we
didn't say it should be this size or
have this many props in it or anything
we we just wait and we let them all kind
of find their own path and go their own
way and it wasn't until you know the end
that we sort of go back through and make
them all work really well gameplay wise
but that that makes it so that the game
plays very different in each map but one
of the things probably the biggest thing
is that is the wildlife you know so so
the monster has to hunt down and kill
and eat wildlife that means he has to
interact with them but also as the
hunters the humans are moving through
the environment they're running into
wildlife and they're having to engage
sometimes just to just to defend
themselves and so the wildlife is it is
a huge and it's a huge factor in the
game for both teams and the monsters
going to use the wildlife to its
advantage as well round Larkin yeah he
can eat him to stage up but he can also
a lot of those wildlife are dangerous
and so a lot of times you'll lead the
hunters into a dangerous wildlife and
inadvertently like the wildlife will
attack the hunters that now it's almost
like the monster has a teammate yeah and
then there's a lot of variety but in the
monsters as well obviously you guys
should we a certain rocket mentality in
Greek yeah we're going to release with
three monsters if you pre-order the game
you'll get the the first monster DLC for
free but the idea is that each monster
plays very differently right I mean so
so far we've had Goliath use our bruiser
we've got crackin who you see here is
you know he's kind of our wizard yes
he's the Krakens of wizard sort of those
great kind of this he a big thing for
Kraken is that he flies right and
Goliath could leap around but goliathus
all ground-based and he's all he does
all the damage directly he comes
they conscious people in the face he
does leave its bleep smashes in charge
attacks it's all like very personal
Kraken stays in the air stays far away
from the team he could can control
electricity so I hits them from range so
it's almost like there's a little bit of
a heat has this middleman the right here
he's casting lightning it's a lightning
attack and he's very far away from the
hunters there so you can just sort of
imagine if you're a hunter the game is
going to play a lot different it
depending on which monster your fight
and you can make some action monsters
with different levels as well it's the
same the same with the hunter so crazy
combinations of hunters and different
monsters that you're facing and that's
one of the things that we love as a
studio we love replayability and left
for dead you could play no mercy a
hundred times and yeah and you probably
did and it was different every time and
and with evolve we wanted to go farther
we knew that was successful and we felt
like there were ways to go farther so
this is kind of a you know mixing
characters and play styles and stuff is
another way to do that that's a lot of
variety that must have proved much of a
challenge for level designers to try and
make you know levels that have allowed
these bruisers to dominate the map but
then also don't have it sort of flying
beasts is yeah they also constant and
for you know I feel said we just played
the game like crazy we play it right now
we play an hour a day every day we've
done that for 40 years yeah and on
Tuesdays and Thursdays we do an
additional two hours on Tuesdays and
Thursdays so it's just a huge amount of
play time to make sure that we get it
right yeah i mean that's working at
turlock that's part of the job you know
it's a certain time every day you're
going to play the game you know what I
strike you know I mean I've worked on
games where that was actually a
punishment but really but yeah yeah yeah
but this one I mean that's that's the
thing that we've sort of discovered over
time is that you know the game doesn't
have to be pretty to be fun and so you
know with those rapid prototypes we know
very quickly whether we've got something
or not
and you know I mean left for dead was
one of those where we immediately knew
we had something good and same thing
with the mole excellent so for folks who
are actually here at pax in Seattle what
do you guys have playable at your booth
what can they actually get their hands
on what's that what do that what can you
actually play at your booth at the
moment like what's available what less
so we've got we've got tues two sets of
hunters really so any class that you
want to play like I said if you play
medic you've got two choices their ass
all has two choices so we've got eight
hunters in total and they all have
different personalities and different
equipment and gear and then we've got
Goliath and Kraken and those two
monsters play completely different so
and I believe we've got all three of our
of our revealed maps in rotation of
school right so you can play a forest
environment a desert environment and an
ice environment and they all have
different wildlife in them as well so
the first time people have been able to
mix and match so you sit down with your
hunters and you decide like are we going
to play with Lazarus who brings people
back from the dead or vow who has a med
gun and can heal people from range you
know on those those things are very
different so you guys are early 2015
right like februari or so yeah februari
and i'm still teen at you said three
months is on launch what about the maps
how much variety got a good ah we've
we've we've confirmed 12 maps there will
be more yep okay maybe there's a more
game modes okay cool so we're all I GLC
you're talking about as well yeah we're
only showing hunt right now but we've
got more game modes and more ways to
play the game which I alluded to a
little bit with the story stuff and
we'll and we'll sort of explore that
stuff later yeah you guys did a great
job on left out of adding content to it
as well post release what's the sort of
tactic with DLC here you guys just is it
monsters primarily more maps different
mode uh well primarily the one thing we
definitely wanted to do out of the gate
because we as gamers have had bad
experiences with this in the past as we
we wanted to make sure that no matter
what we do no matter what comes out if
you never if you never spend a dime on
any deal
see you'll always get to play with
everybody else and our game really
caters to that so that new dlc monster
that's going to come out if you don't
buy him you will still fight against him
okay somebody else who buys him will
probably kick your boat yeah and maps
will maps will be free because we don't
ever want to have to kick anybody out of
a server great don't split the community
that's like that was rule number one and
you know a lot of people we've seen you
know in comments sections and stuff like
that get upset about the LC yeah they
think you know we're trying to milk us
yeah but I mean we sat down and we're
very sort of adamant that we're going to
come up with a DLC plan that we felt
good about as consumers and I think
we've done that certainly you know I
mean hunters and monsters are kind of a
no-brainer I've never I don't think I've
ever been on a project where we had
enough time and money to do everything
we want so you know we've got a lot of
ideas that we can you know keep working
on and the community is really adding to
that as well like as soon as we had a
forums and they knew about Goliath there
were threads that were like what about
this kind of monster what about one that
could burrow what about one that could
go stealth there right so they had you
know the list the list of things that we
could do or is just huge I mean a lot of
a lot of our future plans will largely
be sort of driven by you know yeah what
the community wants I mean we're going
to release the game and I say this all
the time we're going to release the game
and it's not going to be our game
anymore it's going to belong to the
community so we're going to be keeping
you know a very close eye on you know
what do people want what are they
responding positively to what are they
responding negatively to you know and
you know so that will certainly inform
our future path excellence and that
community complain right here at PAX of
course in the north wall that your boot
vinaigrettes thanks so much for coming
in chances but involve enjoy the rest of
packs will be actually get to see some
of the show yeah yeah thanks for having
us not at all our pleasure
you